Gültürkös.
Ich bin zuständige Ärzte für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich Ihnen einfach Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Ja, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Alexander Schlüter.
Alexander Schlüter.
Ich bestabiere Ihren Namen.
Alexander wie A, L, E, X, A, N, D, E, R.
Ja.
Und Schlüter wie S, C, H, L, U mit U, L, C, T, ja, doppelt T, E, R.
Ja, 1T, nur 1T.
1T? Okay, 1T, okay, vielen Dank.
Herr Schlüter, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 24 Jahre alt.
24 Jahre alt?
Sie sind sehr jung.
Weil Sie sich einbauen?
Am 17. Mai 2001.
Okay.
Und wissen Sie aktuell, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie liegen?
Ich bin 1,84 m groß.
Ich bin 1,84 m.
Natürlich wiege 76 kg.
76 kg.
Herr Schlüter, vielen Dank.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für mich werden Sie?
Ja, in den letzten 5 Tagen fühle ich mich sehr müde und schwach.
Ich habe Fieber.
Ich schwitze sehr stark.
Ich habe Halsschmerzen.
Das geht mir nicht gut.
Es tut mir sehr leid zu hören.
Haben Sie Ihren Temperatur gemessen?
Ja, 39 Grad.
Ich habe mehrfach gemessen.
Mehrfach.
Und wo haben Sie Ihre Temperatur gemessen?
Im Mund.
Was haben Sie dagegen eingenommen?
Bis jetzt noch nichts.
Weil das Fieber weiterhin heute so ist, habe ich gesagt,
jetzt muss ich zu Ihnen in die Klinik.
Herr Schlüter, Sie haben gut gemacht.
Sie haben auch Schüttelfrost?
Ja, Schüttelfrost und Schwitzen.
Halsschmerzen.
Mein Hals ist irgendwie dick.
Ich habe den Eindruck, der Hals ist an der Seite viel dicker.
Das ist geschmollt hier alles.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie vielleicht meine Sie mit dicker Halsschmerzen?
Herr Große hat die Lymphknoten am Halsbereich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Lymphknoten sind.
Das müssen Sie dann mal untersuchen. Aber es ist geschwollen.
Geschwollen.
Und geschwollene Hals.
Haben Sie nicht bemerkt, eine große,
wie einem Kestaniengroße?
Ich habe dann noch nicht so genau hingefühlt.
Aber kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay, verstehe.
Herr Schlüter, leiden Sie an Schildröse und Probleme?
Nein, Schildröse war bisher noch nie.
Nein.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Halsschmerzen.
Haben Sie auch beim Schluckenschmerzen?
Ja, auch.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz-Kolour?
Von 0 bis 10.
Wobei, kein Schmerzen 10, sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht.
3 bis 4.
3 bis 4 im Ruhestand oder beim Schlucken?
3 in Ruhe und 4, vielleicht 4 bis 5 beim Schlucken.
Aber nicht mehr.
Okay, im Ruhe.
4 und 5 beim Schlucken.
Okay, verstanden.
Sie haben Fieber.
Sag es mir bitte, ob Ihr Umgebung
englische, beschwerdende Menschen haben.
Ich meine Kollegen, Familien, Mitglieder.
Nein, ich kenne keinen.
Ich bin der Einzige.
Okay, aber was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich studiere Geschichte und Englisch.
Studiere Geschichte.
Das bedeutet, Sie haben jeden Tag viele Menschen kontaktiert, oder?
Ja, aber ich mache im Augenblick mehr Vorbereitung von zu Hause.
Ja, okay, vielleicht.
Herr Schlüter, ist Ihnen übel?
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht, aber jetzt ist mir schon etwas übel.
Ich habe auch jetzt, seitdem ich das Fieber habe, keinen richtigen Appetit.
Wie ich nicht falsch verstanden habe, Sie haben seit 5 Tagen Fieber?
Ja, aber noch nicht ganz so hoch.
Aber seit 5 Tagen, schätze ich, habe ich Fieber.
Ich bin sehr müde und schlapp.
Okay, waren Sie hiernächstes Mal im Ausland?
Ja, ich war so vor 6 Wochen in Thailand.
Wie war Ihre Reise?
War gut, war gut.
Ich habe viel gesehen, war alles gut.
Haben Sie damals irgendwelche Entzündung oder Erkältung gehabt?
Nein, nein.
Super.
Herr Schlüter, sagen Sie mir bitte, ob Sie Yukrais oder Gertsucht haben?
Oder kann man sagen, gelbe Tagteränderung, der Haupt bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay.
Sie haben keine Erbrochen?
Ja.
Ist Ihnen schön, denn ich?
Nein.
Okay.
Gab es etwas, was diese Beschwerden auslösen?
Wissen Sie?
Das weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich habe keine Erklärung.
Haben Sie früher Englische Beschwerden, Englische, vielleicht Mandelentzündung oder?
Nein, habe ich eigentlich nicht so gehabt.
Nein, ich kann mich an so welche Beschwerden nicht erinnern.
Okay, verstanden.
Sie haben, wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Zurzeit nicht gut, seitdem ich das Fieber habe, nicht gut.
Sonst ist es gut, der Appetit, sonst gut.
Wegen Fieber.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab- oder zugehren Normen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Sag mir bitte, ob Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen haben.
Nein, Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung.
Wie sagt das Ihre Urin aus?
Der Urin ist jetzt ein bisschen dunkler, aber ich glaube, das liegt vielleicht daran,
weil ich viel geschwitzt habe.
Ich bemühe mich zu trinken, aber ich glaube, ich habe Flüssigkeit verloren durch Schwitzen.
Sie haben recht.
Wie viel Wasser trinken Sie täglich?
Wie viele Liter Wasser trinken Sie?
Kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Ich trinke Mineralwasser und ich trinke Tee, aber vielleicht habe ich auch etwas zu wenig getrunken in den letzten Tagen.
Vielleicht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Sagt der Stuhl normal aus?
Ja, da ist nichts Auffälliges.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atomnot, Husten und Ausflug?
Nein, ich habe Asthma.
Chronisch habe ich Asthma, aber das ist jetzt nichts schlimmer geworden.
Manchmal habe ich etwas Husten reizt, aber das kenne ich.
Das hat sich nichts verändert.
Ja, stimmt.
Herr Schlüter, schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise ja, aber in den letzten fünf Tagen habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen, wegen dem Fieber.
Wegen Fieber.
Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Ein Kissen.
Okay, das ist ja gut.
Herr Schlüter, Sie haben in den letzten fünf Tagen Fieber, Nachschweiß und Schüttersrost, aber auch die Hauptsache ist Halsschmerzen.
Ich habe auch Halsschmerzen.
Ja, Halsschmerzen habe ich.
Und der Hals ist so etwas, ich habe den einen und der Hals ist dicker als sonst.
Sagen Sie mir bitte, die Schmerzen haben oder werden Sie abtasten?
Nein, so richtig schmerzhaft ist das nicht.
Aber es ist hier so besonders an der Seite geschwollen.
Also spüre ich das.
Besonders seitlich.
Haben Sie in den letzten Leistenbereich oder Achselbereich Vergrößerung bemerkt?
Nein, nein.
Besonders seitlich.
Ja, Sie meinen die Schwellung nicht in der Mitte, sondern seitlich, beidseitig.
Mehr auf der Seite, ja, mehr auf der Seite.
Aber das ist nicht mehr so schmerzhaft?
Nicht wesentlich, nee.
Sind das verschieblich?
Ich habe das nicht untersucht.
Bitte kontrollieren Sie.
Ja, ich habe das nicht überprüft.
Das müssen Sie vielleicht nachher machen, wenn Sie mich untersuchen.
Okay, Herr Schlüter.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, die ich wissen sollte?
Nein, ich habe ja gesagt, ich habe Fieber, ich habe starke Schwitzen.
Ich kann nicht richtig schlucken.
Beim Schlucken tut es mir weh.
Und ich habe diese Schwellung.
Nein, sonst habe ich zurzeit keine akuten anderen Beschwerden.
Hab ich sonst nicht, nee.
Okay.
Herr Schlüter, außer die Apfmabronche alle haben Sie die andere chronische Erkrankung.
Zuckerkrankheit oder Erkrankung?
Nein, Zuckerkrankheit habe ich nicht.
Nein, sonst habe ich eigentlich keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Herr Schlüter, haben Sie vergrößerte Bauchumfang bemerkt
oder Druckgefühl im Bauch bemerkt?
Nein, da habe ich keine Beschwerden.
Und Sie haben keine außer Apfmabronche alle die gewerkschauliche chronische Erkrankungen,
wenn ich richtig feststammel habe?
Nein.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich wurde als Kind operiert.
Da war ich 12 Jahre alt.
Da hatte ich einen Leistenbruch auf der rechten Seite.
Da wurde ich am Leistenbruch...
Überf Jahre?
Ja, am Leistenbruch.
Und dann im Februar, im Februar, diesen Jahres,
wurde ich in der Herzklinik operiert,
weil ich in der Herzscheidewand ein Loch hatte.
Und das musste nach Untersuchungen operiert, verschlossen werden.
Das war Ende Februar.
Das war Ende Februar?
Wissen Sie diese Loch zwischen Herzkammer oder Vorhof?
Nein, das war Herzkammer.
Das, glaube ich, heißt Ventricle, Ventricle septum.
So heißt das, habe ich mir gemerkt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Probleme aktuell mit dem Herzen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich treibe auch Sport inzwischen wieder.
Ich spiele zweimal pro Woche Volleyball.
Das war immer ganz gut.
Bis vor fünf Tagen dann das Fieber kam.
Dann habe ich keinen Sport mehr gemacht,
weil ich gar nicht konnte.
Ich bin noch zur Kontrolle gewesen.
Ich habe sechs Monate lang,
Ende Februar bis Ende August,
musste ich ein Antibiotikum nehmen.
Wenn Eingriffe sind wie beim Zahnarzt,
muss ich ein Antibiotikum nehmen, aber nur sechs Monate.
Jetzt hatte ich vor zwei Wochen,
wurde mir ein Zahn rausoperiert.
Der war kaputt zerstört.
Das war vor zwei Wochen.
Und Sie bekommen kein Antibiotikum.
Da habe ich kein Antibiotikum bekommen.
Nein, keine Antibiotikum.
Wann war Ihre letzte Kardiologe besucht?
Die letzte Kardiologe war vor der Reise nach Thailand.
Also ungefähr vor acht Wochen.
War das alles normal?
Der Kardiologe war zufrieden.
Vor acht Wochen.
Alles normal.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme erst mal ein Buddesspray.
Das sind Kätzchen, die muss ich zweimal am Tag inhalieren.
Und dann vor dem Sport nehme ich manchmal noch Salbutamolspray.
Vor dem Sport manchmal Salbutamolspray.
Sie haben gesagt, chronische Asmobronchiale.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Asmobronchiale?
Ja, das ist schon länger.
Seit mindestens 10, 12 Jahren.
Das wurde auch getestet.
Ich bin allergisch auf bestimmte Getreidesorten.
Getreide, wenn das Getreide reif wird.
Und gestreides Staub bei der Ernte.
Und auf Hausstaub.
Das heißt Kreuzallergie, oder?
Ja, ich habe auch eine Hyposensibilisierung gemacht.
Aber das hat nur, der Erfolg war nicht so gut.
Es hat etwas geholfen, aber ich habe mehr davon versprochen.
Wie lange dauert die Hyposensibilisation?
Das war ziemlich lange.
3 Jahre.
Das ist aber schon einige Jahre her.
Aber nicht so erfolgreich.
Aus der Hausstaub und Getreide Probleme.
Alergen und Unverträglichkeiten.
Haben Sie andere Alergen und Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Medikamenta-Allergen?
Nicht bekannt, nee.
Rauchen Sie Herr Schlüter?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke so ein bis zweimal in der Woche eine Flasche Bier.
Aber Sie haben früher auch nicht geraucht, oder?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Droge?
Nein.
Lieben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die Eltern leben noch.
Der Vater ist 52 Jahre alt.
Er hat auch Asthma.
Und die Mutter ist auch 52 Jahre alt.
Er hatte vor 3 Jahren Brustkrebs.
Er wurde operiert und mit Chemotherapie behandelt.
Auch mit Bestrahlung.
Aber es geht ja ganz gut.
Und welche Seite?
Rechts.
Chemotherapie und Radiotherapie?
Chemotherapie hatte sie und Bestrahlung.
Aber das ist inzwischen abgeschlossen.
Okay, super. Wunderbar.
Haben Sie Schwester?
Ja, ein Bruder, der ist 18 Jahre alt.
Er hat auch Asthma.
Und er hat Neurodermitis.
Dann habe ich noch eine Schwester.
Die ist 20 Jahre alt.
Die hat eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Und auch anfangs hatte sie eine Unterfunktion der Schilddrüse.
Aber jetzt ist das inzwischen normalisiert.
Okay, das heißt, sie nimmt regelmäßig eine Medikamente, oder?
Ja, das muss sie.
Sie haben gesagt, ich bin schütz studieren.
Aber nur haben sie arbeiten nicht.
Ich habe nicht mehr gearbeitet.
Ich bin ledig.
Okay, haben Sie ein Festpartner?
Ja.
Okay, ein Partner?
Partnerin.
Ich bin ein Kinder, sehr leicht.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Kinder, keine.
Sehr gut.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich bin schon fertig.
Nein?
Hauptsache Sie können mir bald helfen.
Ja, wir müssen sofort bei Ihnen untersuchen durchführen.
Und danach, ich muss sofort Ihren Hals untersuchen durchführen.
Mandel untersuchen durchführen.
Gegebenenfalls einen...
einen Untersuchung in Hals.
Einen Ausstrich machen.
Ich werde auch in Laban untersuchen.
Und ich werde auch Torax durchführen.
Torax?
Torax, das heißt Torax.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit.
Ja, eine Kollege fragt geimpft.
Geimpft?
Ja, vorstandig geimpft.
Bevor ich nach Thailand gefahren bin, war ich nochmal bei einem Reisemediziner.
Und er hat alles untersucht.
Ich habe ausreichend Impfung, Hepatitis,
und Tethanus und Difterie.
Das weiß ich, habe ich alles gemacht.
Und ja, ich bin ja noch nicht so alt, dass ich jetzt...
Koichusten?
Das bin ich als Kind geimpft worden, ja.
Und das ist, glaube ich, ausreichend auch...
Ja.
Ich glaube schon, dass ich erstmal ganz gut vom Impfen her ganz gut bin, ja.
Okay.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit.
Und vielleicht gibt es Fragen von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Wir haben ja nun mehrere Ebenen in diesem Fall.
5 Tage Fieber.
Eine Reiseanamnese.
Eine Operationsanamnese.
Ihr fragt einen Kollege Malaria Profilaxe.
Nein, ich habe keine Malaria Mittel genommen in Thailand.
Es hieß, da, wo ich hinfahre, sei Malaria nicht so ein Problem.
Ich habe andere Menschen getroffen, die das gemacht haben,
Malaria Profilaxe, aber ich habe das nicht gemacht.
Ja, sind Sie vielleicht mit Ihrer Partnerin gereist?
Oder dort nach Thailand, meine ich?
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber meine Partnerin mit.
Aber der geht es gut.
Ja, geht es gut.
Und keine Probleme.
Schön gezunabene Herr Oberarsch.
Ich habe einen neuen Partnerin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit dafür?
Ja, habe ich.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Schlueter, er ist 24 Jahre alt, geboren am 17. Mai 2001.
Er ist 1,84 Meter groß und wiegt 76 kg.
Herr Schlueter, starte sich bei uns heute vor,
wegen seit 5 Tagen bestehende Fatigue, Schwachgefühl und Fieber.
Okay.
Laut der Angabe des Patienten,
dass Fieber 39 Grad Celsius sind und mehrfach per Oral gemessen werden.
Ja, per Oral gemessen.
Okay.
Das weitere klackte er über, Hyperhydrosa, Schütterfrost
und Halsdrückendegefühl im Hals, auch dies und dysphagie.
Ja.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt im Ruhestand bei 3 von 10.
Im Schmuckchen, 4 bis 5 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala.
Hat der Patient über Schwellungen berichtet?
Natürlich.
Er hat gesagt, dass die Halsbereiche,
insbesondere seitlich, Schwellungen haben.
Sie können sagen, der Patient berichtet über eine gewisse
Servikale Schwellung.
Wir wissen ja noch nicht genau, was sie haben gefragt.
Sind es Knoten?
Sie haben nach Lymphknoten gefragt.
Patient hat nur gesagt, es ist geschwollen.
Wir sagen Servikale Schwellungen.
Der Patient berichtet über das beidseitige Servikalbereich
Teilbordsterte Schwellungen.
Ja, Schwellungen, einfach Schwellung.
Schwellung ist ja schon eine Vergrößerung.
Okay.
Darüber hinaus sagt der Patient vor 2 Wochen,
wegen Zahnprobleme,
Zahnarsklienik behandelt.
Im wurde der Zahn gezogen.
Der Zahn oder gezogen?
Zahn gezogen.
Wenn Sie den Begriff für ein Zahn ziehen,
dann haben Sie eine Zahnextraktion.
Der Patient berichtet über eine Zahnextraktion vor 2 Wochen.
Er wurde der Zahn gezogen.
Ja, Extraktion.
Extrahiert.
Extrahiert, extrahiert aus Lateinisch heißt er rausziehen.
Und darüber außer dem habe er erweitert,
dass er vor 6 Wochen in Thailand gereist.
Ja, und dort aber habe er keine irgendwelche Entzündung gehabt.
Keine Auffälligkeiten, oder es war unauffällig.
In Thailand war er.
War er in Malaria-Gebiet?
Nein, das ist nicht.
Hat er eine Malaria-Prophylaxe gemacht?
Er hat nicht.
Er hat keine Prophylaxe bekommen.
Aber das Gebiet ist nicht problematisch.
Ein Malaria-Gebiet.
Gut, das.
Ja, okay.
Also ich habe jetzt Folgendes behalten.
Der Herr Schlüter ist 24 Jahre alt.
Er berichtet, dass er sich seit 5 Tagen nicht wohl fühlt.
Er hat eine Leistungsknick.
Er hat eine Fatiksymptomatik.
Er hat febrile Temperaturen bis 39 Grad oral gemessen.
Er klagt über Hyperhidrosis, über Dysphagie und eine gewisse Schwellung
im Zervikalbereich.
Er berichtet, dass vor 2 Wochen ein Zahn extrahiert wurde.
Eine Zahnextraktion vor 2 Wochen.
Er sei vor 6 Wochen, hatte er eine Reise nach Thailand gemacht.
Dort gab es keine Auffälligkeiten.
Es ist ihm gut gegangen.
Er hat dort keine Malaria-Prophylaxe gemacht.
Gut, fahren Sie bitte fort.
Danke.
Zudem, leider er an, naus er, ich werde bedingt in Somni
wegen Fibar.
Er konnte nicht so gut schlafen.
Und von Innenbet观.
Die Frage nach Düstnö, Kusten und Atemnot
wurde verneint.
Das war auch mit Icteros.
Evigratativ Anahm neise ist unauffällig bis auf Dunkla Urine.
Er trinkt nicht so viel Wasser.
Zu den Erkrankungen gab er an, dass er seit zwölf Jahren chronische Asthma hat.
Er wurde eine Herniotomie wegen Leistenbruch oder in Gewinnern rechts.
Ja, ich war im Alter von zwölf.
Er wurde sechs Monate Antibiotik bekommen.
Er hat eine Erkrankung von der Medikamente, die er in der Früh geblieben hat.
Und vor dem Sport nimmt er manchmal Cybertomolch Break.
Okay, okay. Was für ein Sport macht der Patient? Wissen Sie das?
Ja, er macht Sport. Ich habe geschrieben.
Volleyball.
Ja, Volleyball. Sehr gut.
Noch eine Frage zum Asthma-Brontiale.
Er hat seit zwölf Jahren Asthma-Brontiale.
Ist da eine Diagnostik gemacht worden?
Warum er Asthma-Brontiale hat?
Ja, er hat viele Diagnostische Untersuchungen bekommen.
Und er hat Hausstab und Getreideallergie.
Der Patient hat also ein allergisches Asthma-Brontiale.
Ja, er hat auch Immuntherapie bekommen.
Aber es war nicht erfolgreich.
Nicht so gut. Okay.
Bitte schön.
Hausstab und Getreideallergie hat er keine andere Allergie oder Verträglichkeiten.
Er ist nicht raucher. Er trinkt nur ein bis zwei Flächen via in der Woche.
Ja.
Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Kommen wir nun zu Familienanahmnese.
Sein Vater leidet an Asthma-Brontiale.
Seine Mutter...
Wie alt ist der Vater?
52 Jahre alt.
Seine Mutter erlitt vor drei Jahren Mama Karcinom-Rechs.
Sie wurde operiert und Chemo- und Radioterapie bekommen.
Aber sie ist gerade gut.
Ja, okay.
Herr Schlüter hat zwei Geschwester.
Ein Bruder.
Seine Bruder ist 18 Jahre alt.
Und er leidet an Asthma-Brontiale.
Außerdem leidet er an Neurodermitis.
Und er hat auch eine Schwester.
Sie ist leidet an Vergrößerte Schilddröse.
Ja, kennen Sie den Fachbegriff für Vergrößerte Schilddröse?
Vergrößerte Diffuse.
Vergrößerte Schilddröse.
Diffusa.
Ja, Stroma.
Da unten wurde das im Chat geschrieben.
Sie hat wahrscheinlich eine Stroma-Diffusa.
Ja, Stroma-Diffusa.
Ja, wenn sie einen Knoten hätte.
Dann hätte sie eine Stroma-Nodosa.
Mit Knoten.
Eine Stroma-Diffusa ist nur eine Vergrößerung.
Und die Stoffwechselage.
Hypotheoriosas.
Sie hat eine Hypotheoriosas.
Und jetzt ist sie Euteriot.
Der Stoffwechsel hat sich normalisiert.
Ja, das ist die Familienanalyse.
Jetzt würde ich von Ihnen wissen,
was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja, eigentlich kann ich sagen,
muss man zuerst einfacher denken.
Anginatonsilaris.
Infektiozemononiklios.
Linforma.
Und
bei der Särukel-Linfknoten.
Aber wenn es erschmärtsen hat,
hat er bemerkt, hat kein erschmärtsen,
bei der gross-särukel-Linfknoten.
Vielleicht hochte ich Linforma.
Okay.
Infektiv wegen der
Sandflasche.
Zahnextraktion.
Und danach passiert eine Lymphadenitis.
Aber er hat auch Schmerzhaft, ich denke.
Ja, dies vergirrt,
hat er aber Lymphknoten,
haben keine Schmerzen.
Und
wir wissen es nicht.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Wir wissen es nicht genau.
Wichtig ist ja, dass Sie den Patienten natürlich
dann untersuchen körperlich.
Und dann werden Sie, denke ich, diese
servikalen Schwellungen palpieren.
Und auch etwas schräftiger palpieren, um zu sehen, ob er
eine Spleinumwege-Lie hat.
Ja, er hat keine, aber
bisher nichts gesagt.
Aber eine Spleinumwege-Lie muss ja nicht unbedingt
einen vergrößerten Bauchumfang machen.
Aber ja, gut, denken Sie nochmal an seine Reise
und denken Sie nochmal an seine OP.
Ja, manche
Sceptareffekt, Operationen, Infektiv
und Carditis. Kann man denken, Infektiv
und Carditis? Man muss zumindest das im Kopf behalten.
Ja.
Aktuell nach der Zahnextraktion kann es ja sowieso sein,
er hat keine
Antibiotika-Behandlung, Begleitbehandlung
bekommen.
Honartöre, was ja üblich ist, wenn Trikel
Sceptareffekt und danach nicht unbedingt mehr.
Aber er war auch in Thailand.
Und wenn er sagt, er war nicht in Malaria-Gebiet,
dann würde ich trotzdem
eine Kollegin schließe, dass man muss eine Malaria auf alle Fälle ausschließen.
Also der Patient
kommt für viele Erkrankungen in Frage.
Ich finde die Erste haben Sie schon ganz richtig gesagt.
Ich würde auch als Erstes durchaus an eine infektiöse Mononucleose
denken.
Das muss nicht immer mit starken anderen Symptomen
hergehen, aber es kann durchaus sein.
Das wird man auch relativ schnell herausfinden.
Natürlich muss man den Patienten auch
kardiologisch untersuchen. Ganz sicher.
Ja, und dicke Blut
untersuchen. Genau, große dicke Tropfen
im Blut, da können Sie schnell die Malaria
wahrscheinlich ausschließen. Aber das sind
wichtige Differenzialdiagnosen.
Also sicherlich der Verdacht bezieht sich auf mehrere Felder.
Sie müssen nur möglichst dran denken,
dass sie das alles beachten.
Aber das haben Sie gemacht, finde ich gut.
Es war so ein etwas vielschichtiger Fall
und ich würde mich auch nicht drauf verlassen,
wenn ein Patient sagt, ich war in Thailand,
aber ich war nicht in Malaria-Gebiet.
Das ist ja immer mal so eine Sache.
Es kann in der Grenze sein, es kann sich verschieben
in einem Jahr, vielleicht durch eine Regenzeit
und was auch immer. Da wäre ich vorsichtig,
gerade wenn er keine Malaria-Profilaxe gemacht hat,
dann würde ich zumindest immer
eine Malaria ausschließen im Labor.
Zumindest dran denken, nicht außer Acht lassen.
Und das andere denke ich auch
bei der Herzvoroperation am Herzen
und jetzt die Zahnextraktion.
Ja, gut.
Ja, erst mal vielen Dank. Ich finde, das haben Sie auch sehr gut gemacht
und ruhig gemacht.
Sagen Sie ruhig, wenn der Patient so fragt,
ja, was kann ich denn haben?
Seien Sie zurückhalten, dass Sie jetzt sagen,
ich möchte als erstes mal Ihren Hals untersuchen,
haben Sie gesagt. Das würde ich gar nicht sagen.
Ich würde jetzt Sie gleich gründlich körperlich untersuchen.
Das betrifft ja dann nicht nur den Hals,
sondern Sie hören den Patienten ab,
Sie palpieren, Sie untersuchen
Seine Abdomen, seine Lymphknotenstationen.
Dann würde ich nicht sagen, ich werde gleich
genau Ihren Hals untersuchen, da, wo es ihm wehtut.
Natürlich auch, aber das würde ich gar nicht sagen.
Ich würde Sie jetzt gleich gründlich untersuchen
und dann werde ich Sie natürlich auch
mit dem Oberarzt vorstellen.
Sie müssen auf alle Fälle erst einmal hier bei uns bleiben,
dass wir uns erst mal ein genaues Bild machen.
Das würde ich so sagen.
Gut, ja, erst mal vielen Dank.
Dann werden wir uns vor Ihrer Prüfung
in Freiburg, Sie sind doch in Freiburg dann, ne?
Nein, Münster.
Ich habe die anderen Kollegen da irgendwo in Freiburg.
Sie sind Münster, ist ja auch schön.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen für die Prüfung alles gut.
Danke.